the moment it all became very real
budget day and before the markets opened
the Bank of England announced a shot cut
in interest rates emergency measures for
critical times the Bank is announcing
today a comprehensive and timely package
of measures to help UK households and
businesses bridge across the economic
disruption caused by kovat 19 the
economic risk of coronavirus now hitting
home as the scale of the public health
risk hit the heart of government health
minister anand dean Dory's becoming one
of the 463 UK cases she been in number
10 just days ago carrying on as normal
for now the new chancellor tasked with
delivering a budget in the most
challenging of times just get into
Parliament difficult enough the
Chancellor's stuck between two very
different budgets the coronavirus action
plan and his five-year investment
programme mr. Chancellor of the
Exchequer to the most pressing matters
first coronavirus will have a
significant impact on our economy but it
will be temporary I will do whatever it
takes to get our nation through it five
billion extra for the NHS whatever extra
resources our NHS needs to cope with
coronavirus it will get 7 billion to
help businesses today I am announcing a
new temporary coronavirus business
interruption loan scheme banks will
offer loans of up to 1.2 million pounds
to support small and medium-sized
businesses and reassurances for worried
workers rather than having to go to the
doctor's you will soon be able to obtain
a sick note by contacting one one one
then to the long term plan 10 years of
Tory austerity over the spending taps
turned on all funded by the biggest rise
in borrowing for 30 years
this is the first budget of a new decade
the first in almost 50 years outside the
European Union first of this new
government hundreds of billions of
capital investment for roads rail and
broadband billions more for public
services to labor clear it's too little
too late we're going into this crisis
with our public services on their knees
and as today's figures confirm with a
fundamentally weak economy which is now
flatlining with zero growth even before
the impact of coronavirus and on his own
benches the old guard defending the
great torre tradition of spending
restraint while spending a lot of money
may be popular and may seem the natural
thing to do there is of course that
necessity of having a realistic
assessment of the longer-term impact the
fiscal rules that we set out in our
manifesto are important sticking to
those rules in normal times is what
separates us from the parties opposite
this a budget drawn up before
coronavirus changed everything the new
chancellor tried to do both things today
he tried to vaccinate the economy while
also trying to set out a five-year
vision for Britain but ministers know
that this government won't be judged on
what happens to Britain in five years
time it will be judged on how it handles
this pandemic in the next five days five
weeks five months a conservative
Chancellor in number 11 but borrow in
from Labour's playbook a sign of Boris
Johnson's intent to hold on to his new
political ground but that will depend
not on promises made today but the
actions he takes to steer us through
what is about to come Beth Rigby Sky
News Westminster